hey guys welcome back to the warlord
podcast honestly how good has it been
the last few weeks having these genuine
superstars of our game coming on and
openly sharing their stories and even
today guys guests do not get much bigger
than him but before we get to it if you
have been enjoying this podcast please
continue to share it it is very much
appreciated or if you listen to it on
apple go give it a five star review
apparently that helps out heaps as well
but if you really love the podcast and
you've got a business which is keen to
grow then now is your chances we are
looking for sponsors to partner up with
waterlab for season three which is going
to be bigger and better than ever a
great opportunity for you to hit the
ears of all the massive lads male and
female from around the world who tune
into this podcast if you are keen get in
touch through waterloo.com or the
instagram page
but anyway that's enough from me let's
get to the real star of the show roll
the intro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello today guys i'm honored to be in
the presence of greatness not only is he
one of the greatest hurricanes of all
time he's also been consistently one of
the best players in the world where he
has dominated the international scene
with the all blacks but what really sets
this lad apart is what he's done off the
field he's created a personal brand he's
hosted one of the best podcasts to exist
and he sells some of the best clothes on
the market he's even been his own agent
where he's been able to sign himself on
with new zealand rugby for another four
years this man is leading the way and
inspiring many including myself it is
the great lad the very great lad adi
server welcome brother thanks brother
thanks for having me on my man
you know more than myself then i know
myself
mate you've just done so much in your
career already man it's so cool to see
yeah i mean i'm just grateful to be
where i am today bro and just trying to
trying to be me while i'm while i'm at
and be authentic um so yeah the process
and the journey has been uh
been pretty cool so far and what you've
done around inspiring other athletes and
other people
has been so massive including myself i
remember when i was looking to set up
this podcast you were the one who really
gave me the confidence to jump in
because i remember hitting you up
because i wasn't sure if it would be you
know stepping on your toes or jumping
into the same sort of space and i
remember you just giving me the full
confidence to just go at it get after it
and been enjoying it ever since man it's
awesome to see you do
jump on and do it i remember the
conversation and jumping the mics off to
you yeah you're staying a little bag
yeah man it's it's awesome to see it's
kicking off and and the lads jumping on
board i think it's important too to have
like a platform like uber it's a safe
space for us athletes to
to come you know if someone else wants
to ask me to jump on i'll be more
declined to to do it but when you have
the also you know doing his thing
of course
i obviously really appreciate that
because like you're a massive and you
have been a massive influence for like i
said a lot of people including myself
but not just in the podcast world you
also recently just been your own agent
signed for another four years talk to me
about this whole process
but it's um it was pretty crazy like it
started off as a thought and you know
obviously you know you know all players
like myself and petty you know we talk
around like you know how players can be
better than getting what they're worth
and contract deals and
uh you know i reached that point in my
career where i was like i experienced
and
kind of knew a lot of what went in on
the contract and picked up on what my
agent was doing and i thought man if it
was the time to try and do it it would
be now
especially
with the timing around how i was playing
and you know i had a lot of leverage to
negotiate um so
talk to my wife she wasn't really keen
on it she just thought i was being bots
but
but yeah i kind of just did it and yeah
went through the process bro i i to be
honest i just wanted to see at the table
and to be able to hear the news from new
zealand rugby first hand instead of
having like a middleman to me
do that so
it was more to have a seat at the table
and actually like just fight for myself
and really which is hard to do because
it's in our natural
nature to not talk ourselves up yeah but
in terms of negotiating your contract
you kind of have to and that's something
that i had to get comfortable with bro
so
yeah the process would be
challenging as well but um
like really kind of like glad i heard it
because i learned so much um just in
that process did you always feel
comfortable at the table and stuff when
you're talking about your contract well
like because we obviously would catch up
at cafes with the dude that i was
negotiating with
and well before i get in i'll like sit
in my car and i'm like okay
i like i like pray i'll pray i'll be
like lord give me the words and the
wisdom go in there and and whatever
happens it's um it's your doing and it's
whatever you want so i went in there and
then
it was just yeah it was free flowing and
to be honest the nju guys were actually
really really kind of good
because obviously they knew kind of new
to negotiating it so yeah they made the
process a lot easier and kind of better
but there were times when we uh i
challenged them and we pushed and it got
heated and um it was the baits
so
yeah it was me it was cool it is cool
did you have any other offers that you
were bouncing between or was it just
purely going with new zealand rugby to
start yeah well it was new zealand rugby
to start bro um we happy here in
wellington so
it was more so getting that security and
that and that bag while we can
and also this stuff that i want to
achieve here as well and the king's
jersey and the black jersey if i'm lucky
enough so
there's always been ends at iu bro but
kind of around the super side like
obviously with moana pacifica
um oh yeah that was kind of like
that kind of popped in my mind and
that's probably one of the reasons why i
started the kingston 23 just to keep my
options open yeah and what what other
clauses have you got on the contract did
you get right down to the detail any
sabbaticals any um out clauses any
crypto
but to be funny towards the end because
to be fair um like shout out to my man
was a
he kind of when i was on end of tour i
kind of went back to him and asked if he
could kind of help me close the deal off
and look at little the intricacies of
the contract so he kind of helped close
that deal yeah uh but yeah pretty much i
asked was in one of my one-off payments
if i could have half
bitcoin
he was like it's got to be like no way
at least i tried
uh but uh yeah post post real comfort 24
i have a
option to go and play offshore obviously
in japan for for six months and yeah if
that's an option
um if i don't do that bro i i have an
option just to take the whole super
rugby off six months off yeah or 40 um
and just have a break with the family um
so yeah a few options there bro which is
which is pretty nice and i'm real
privileged and honored bro to to
actually have that
mate you sound like you've absolutely
nailed your contract
where was addie severe the agent when i
was playing
oh no
but bro like to be honest it only
happened and i was only able to to be
able to negotiate just from talking to
other players because obviously with
agents they know who's on who what's on
what so they're able to like put you
wherever
where i didn't have that information so
a lot of it was around like shout out to
the boys that that helped me along the
way i can't name them but i kind of knew
where everyone was at and where i kind
of fit and yeah you know what i mean so
uh yeah right at the top
[Music]
so
now i'd like those lads helped out as
well and it just shows where players
when players start talking amongst each
other in a safe space
it's the players have the power that's
so cool and what talk to me about the
video that video i watched was one of
the best watches i've seen obviously
acting classism and going wow some of
this stuff oh man lucky you're not in
the cage of that [ __ ] video i would
have been
i would have been to shrimp
because i love that one that was so good
i was actually um
i actually was inspired by bobby wagner
he's a nfl player
and he negotiated as a contract and he
did something similar yeah when he
announced his signing
so i thought knowing me mate i was just
like i'm out the gate sometimes for five
years
so i just like [ __ ] i'm gonna do it
so i just did it
so cool how long did that take you to
act out was it all sort of one take or
did you have a few blue pizzas
i was i wasn't in my cuber so oh yeah
yeah it was it was pretty crack up um i
was kind of in a rush because new
zealand rugby wanted to announce it
hurricanes wanted to announce it
but i wanted to announce it first
so like so i had to shoot all the
content and i gave it to some of the
boys to eat it up so
few takes mate
a few sweats but it was all good
so good it was worth it one of the best
watches you'll see if you haven't seen
it already go and watch that so good
also a little bit about the agents do
you think players can sort of jump into
that role more often do you think more
players should be their own agent and do
you think even the young guys should be
able to get into this yeah that's a good
question uh jab i like i don't know
about the young fellas because obviously
they need their help and guidance
around that but i think it's all up to
the individual
around it like i've since i released
that video i have guys that are at super
or itm level that have said that they've
just negotiated their own deals as well
so that's awesome to hear but just all
depends on the timing
but what i do encourage is players being
more aware of what goes into the
contract so they can
question and challenge the agents yeah
um around that instead of just the agent
going mate this is a great offer great
deal and you're like cool and then just
sign the dot by actually doing a bit of
homework
and understanding it that that can go a
long way 100 i hear so often from
players that they're not happy with
their agent and stories like that some
guys don't even know what they're paying
them things like that and you're just
like you got to sort of educate yourself
around this and sort of look after
yourself first
100 bro 100 percent it's like you have a
contract and then you get another
contract and it's like it doesn't even
involve that much work
but agents still get cut from it so it's
like you know it's asking the agent and
challenging that you know and another
space around the whole agent space is
the nft space which is obviously growing
a lot um it's going to be a huge part of
i think rugby agents work going forward
in the future where where are you at
with your nft have you got one coming i
reckon you're if my money's on one
someone to drop it first that's you yeah
well i actually
signed with a company called humble
who's an american-based company that a
like a web 3
platform and it was initially like now
let's go at first but as the whole nft
space has just kind of like come out
there's a lot more to it than
you know than just bringing it out and
making sure it's a cash grab um like
talking to like dc and that like you
want to build community and be smart
around when you bring out so i'm in the
process of trying to work towards
something and bringing something out for
for the fans and and for the collectors
out there that love footy it's just i
don't have a timeline yet but but yeah
yeah it should be pretty cool bro and
like you say
nfts are the new space right now man and
crypto so
yeah it's pretty buzzy mate that's
exciting and what you you talked about
your community but one thing you've done
really well has built a really good
community around your profile as an
athlete you've done things like uh
pre-season camps you've gone for walks
with your fans um you've obviously got
your clothing company which is her
singing and your podcast all these
things have sort of developed the
community that you've created so nft
would just be an extension of that for
you really wouldn't it yeah all the
things that like that community walk the
training camp you know when you do like
giveaways for signed rugby jersey
training gear
nfts just become like a ticket to all
those things so like
i could release say two
one of one nfts and whoever owns that
gets
uh one of my all blacks playing jerseys
that year and my all blacks playing
boots you know and that smart contract
or those real life collectibles will
last for years just adding little things
real life objects to the nft's
experiences
um i think that's where i'm trying to
kind of head towards it's just a matter
a matter of how much time i have in
terms of doing like if it's a one-on-one
coaching or something like that yeah
right that's the space that's definitely
the space it's going to go and yeah mate
your one would be worth the most what
you do some of those sessions oh
i'd love to be able to go one of those
so
um
gold nft jeez that will be going for
megamax
oh yeah one dollar
[Laughter]
and you're obviously just back from your
tour um all the guys i've spoken to so
far had no family they were just out
there loving life on the golf course so
how hard was it for you with your lovely
wife and two kids hmm
yeah
like at the start bro it was like hard
like a lot of anxiety and just the
unknown like we left the country and the
country was a level four yeah so you
know like
you could imagine you know leaving your
wife and the kids
in in their own house locked down
but but as the time we're not on tour it
wasn't too bad you facetimed the family
but i think
there's a lot of stuff going on on tour
that kind of keeps your mind ticking
over
yeah i actually really enjoyed it bro i
look back bro and it was probably the
best thing that could happen for an all
blacks team
being away for 15 weeks and building the
connections and yeah and just like
around that the lads just making up fun
you know the albu albies and jordi's
playing golf and stuff like that yeah i
i enjoyed it and there are times where
it's tough but
having the lads around really helped did
you get out on the course for a hit
right
terrible bro no i haven't yet i think
i'm going to start with the basics and
just play in the miramar course or jordy
just get a few lessons first
[Laughter]
but your form on tour was uh as always
exceptional mate some of the
performances you put in were like always
world class you even had the opportunity
to lead the all blacks what was that
experience like yeah man it was it was
probably one of my highlights in my
career so far brother uh yeah yeah
massive massive year when i looked back
at it bro um oh it caught me off guard
bro i was blinded by you know like
there's guys in the team
that i
i really really respect in the high
regard and so i thought like
how like i didn't even think about it
you know i was just like yeah let's go
and then got pulled aside and
[ __ ] my pants very like
it was like
like shaking
but i was it was pretty awesome
experience
i learned a lot bro around leadership
and
how to kind of like
try and run a team and and the boys um
but i'm grateful i had bears and guzz
and tj and codes and albs just around me
bro they were awesome but um
yeah it was a cool experience bro really
enjoyed it pretty scary at times but
yeah yeah it was cool what was that
conversation like do they ask you if you
want to be captain or do they just tell
you that you're going to be captain yeah
you pretty much are he goes oh
i want you to captain this the side yeah
pulled me aside but i literally thought
i was in trouble like i got a text going
i need to catch up with you but i was
thinking in my head oh [ __ ] what have i
done
but thinking
and he was like yeah took me outside
where the pool was and just kind of
set me down and
yeah
he said they wanted me to skip the side
yeah
i wasn't going to say no you can't say
no to there you know so
yeah that was pretty awesome bro i just
grateful as yeah and what's it like
how's your week changed being the
captain and what what sort of changes
does much change
yeah for a heaps does that mean
yeah when you rock up like you know when
you rock up and you're just the player
you can just worry about yourself
getting yourself ready keeping nailing
your role
and and whatnot uh when you're the
leader like you you look across like the
whole team making sure everything's
functioning like driving your leaders
and what messages you want you know and
um and i struggle i struggled at that
like because i struggled having like
those hard
you know conversations um
so just driving the team
um so a lot of changes around that bro
which is something i wasn't used to even
at like drivers meetings like yeah you
know drivers meetings like around the
game and the iq around that
um it was real new to me so and that's
where bears kind of stepped in and
took over because that's his forte and
yeah but it was it was a great learning
experience bro and
just lucky i had those guys next to me
did anything change when you're on the
field or is it just once you're out on
the field it's our business as usual
yeah like a lot i learned like
obviously you know like
myself like
you know penalty yeah go for the corner
let's jump some tries
but
but in test footy bro there's like a
small margins you know so yeah but just
the decisions around the three points
and and going for the five points um
understanding the game and and like how
to close out games and talking to the
ref yeah a lot of that's different but
it wasn't really like a version for me i
just like kind of like yep embrace that
kind of thing and just went along with
it so on those penalties is that
decision the captains or the coaches
send down a message or is it the game
drivers ah that's a mixture of both but
eventually like the captain kind of has
the you know final say so
yeah it's a mixture of both right like
sometimes i look to bears or i look to
jordy because he can kick 70 meters i'll
be like you got it
and you know he's like yeah god i'm so
sorry
so it's a mixture of my father yeah and
your form like we talked i spoke about
before but your form was as always
outstanding um you've just been
nominated for new zealand player of the
year probably for the fifth time in a
row or something what do you put your
form down to
i don't know man not good
i think i'm quite like a simple man so
like i try and keep things real simple
for me and when things are simple and i
know what to do and my roles nailed then
i just trust my instincts and just go
out there and jab like you know and just
play
so at the moment that's been working for
me um next year it may look different i
might have to evolve or change
but yeah so far that's kind of the
formula that i've kind of been been
sticking to is
keeping things simple in my week
which allows me to just go out there and
express myself and what what about your
mindset in a carry because one thing
that you've always been known for is
your leg drive your inability to be
tackled you just keep fighting for every
inch when you've got that ball so what
is it what is your mindset when you are
carrying that ball to be honest i don't
even know myself but like i just i just
get it and
tried running as hard as i can and um
you know if guys can
tackle me down that's awesome
but i just try and go and
go until i get tackled um
i think it's always been in me since i
was little bro like i was one of the
smaller flankers growing up still
considered as a small flanker
so like i've just kind of embedded that
like
mangrove in me that i want to prove
people wrong and i think i've just
carried i've just carried that through
right through
my teenage years to now
so it's um yeah so that's really
kind of where i put it on mate it's i
love it i love watching you carry the
ball you just never go down it was
complete obviously as soon as i was
touched i was trying to place the ball
long
no
you're more you're like silky just
through the gadget
but you talked about being a little
fella and um when you're growing up so
give us a little bit more of a rundown
on your life growing up obviously you
had your big brother who was a superstar
through the grades so how was it living
with him and your family in wellington
yeah but it was like materially like
didn't have much but with a love and
and like the care and you know family
having each other's back that was i was
like we were real rich in that in that
space um
there was only four of us
me jules and mum and dad um small small
family
but yeah growing up bro was awesome like
we had heaps of cousins every sundays
would be at the park playing cricket
basketball tennis the whole lot but yeah
growing up obviously bus kind of paved
the way for me in terms of but the the
rugby side the size he is now was the
start he was was when he was 13 but so
all right
yeah so it was awesome i can
grow up there probably one thing that
kind of did have an effect on me like a
little bit was obviously living in a
shadow and playing in the shadow like i
wasn't i was the smallest guy and people
just thought oh there's julian's brother
he's going to be this amazing freak
but i was just like this this little
scrawny skinny kid that kind of didn't
have the freakish abilities yeah which i
think kind of that's where i instilled
like the [ __ ] i'm gonna work hard and
prove people wrong and and i think
that's where this stem but but the
upbringing was awesome very rich and
loved and owed pretty much everything
that we have been blessed to our parents
and the things they did when we were
young and getting us the games and
sacrificing a lot bro so did you always
think that you were going to be able to
become a professional rugby player as
like jewels
um
it's weird bro because you i was always
in the rugby system so like i was like
yeah never really thought professionally
um it wasn't until my last year of
college you know making schools and
stuff like you'll be like oh yo that
could be a thing or two but
kind of never really believed it until
it happened
if that makes sense yeah like always
have that doubt but when it happens i
was like oh [ __ ] okay here i go and that
first step was with new zealand sevens
is that right yeah bro um out of school
into the seventh set up with touchy well
you know what
oh
that was that was tough but uh you know
i was my first plane ride though was
when i was 18 out of college in
wentwolf7 so
yeah traveling to like around the world
bro 18 was pretty special and yeah from
then on my career just kicked off bro
how did you find being in that camp
obviously there's a good group of lads
on that in that camp at the time eh so
um how do you find that
well i love today like you know when you
grow up and you think like the
professional rugby environment it's like
these like top athletes
like they're just like yeah they're like
you know kings and then you get to know
them just like ordinary dudes they like
to have a laugh
play pranks you know like flip the rooms
and stuff like that so
it was pretty eye-opening and um pretty
humbling to be around like tomasi farmer
and dj forbes
you know all those guys um it was pretty
cool man did the guys ever prank you i
couldn't imagine the guys pranking you
too bad too much respect no yeah we're
not obviously when you're young but you
you they don't care your first year
wow
you know when they flip the rooms they
get your key room key and they flip the
rooms yeah or they or they throw the
sheet over you and beat your
yeah
good game
yeah good times so then how what where
why did the seven stop was that because
of super rugby yeah
obviously sevens and then made the lions
the following year
and then i think played my first year
lions and then got a cane's contract and
obviously like back then like sevens was
like a stepping stone for guys to kick
their 15's career off
um so yeah stephen's kind of stopped
once i made the lions um in the 15s game
and
i love stevensburg because like
that's where i kind of learned how to
like just play in the y channels like
you know try to do the gooses and the
steps and the the long skunky passes and
you learn all those
and you learn all those kind of skill
sets bro and it just becomes naturally
part of your game
so i really loved that um about the
sevens but yeah kind of stopped when i
made
um pro 40 in the 15s game and what was
it like going into that those setups in
wellington the first wellington lines
and then the hurricanes yeah but
shooting my pads too you know like
rubbing shoulders with guys that
i was watching on tv the year before
that was pretty special bro like
for me it was all around like just
putting my head down
and earning the respect of the older
guys and that was mainly through action
so i highly spoke bro like
i just
and just like earned the respect through
mahi and my training and how i go about
my work oh you definitely did that was
at the end of your first season with the
hurricanes where you got called in to be
an apprentice for the all blacks the
first ever yeah i think 213 yeah yeah
how was that being called as an
apprentice and what was it like
travelling with the all blacks knowing
you're not going to play at such a young
age yeah but it's pretty it was pretty
funny story like you know how you hear
guys that get the first phone call that
they've made the all blacks yeah for me
but it was different because
their apprentice here i was with sas and
we're just chilling and i got a random
phone call
and it was like hey it's darren chan
here from the all blacks and i was like
because you know joe's toys are saying
like you get a call if you made the team
so i was like
i've made it i've made it
i'm saying that's like are you staring
it's hard to use that
i just want to say you didn't make the
all blacks you haven't made the squad
and i was like
[Laughter]
and then uh and then he was like oh but
we want to take you on a princess so
you're officially not in the squad but
you're part of the team yeah so like
that was like a anti-climax kind of way
and then
216 obviously we had we won the super
title
and there had been a lot of talk around
me making the a b so i was kind of like
predicted so when i when my name got
announced it was kind of like a
yay but not not as like a a massive
announcement but it would have been it
would have been more like a finale for
you because i mean you it was three
years after and
probably could have should have made
that side
all three years post that apprentice
yeah did you feel no
looking back but i was probably too
young and my body physically probably
wasn't ready
um in that space and
like you know when you're young you
believe the media hype that you showed
and there was a lot of talk by looking
back at it bro i'm grateful that i had
that time to kind of develop as a
flanker and
mentally as well but yeah the apprentice
here was awesome bro like
again i'm rubbing shoulders with richie
mccoy and kevin reed yeah
oh right like i was lucky i had bus
there you know when you have the older
bro in the team
like you just naturally fall into like
you hang out with her and ma'am victor
you know the brothers yeah so um
that was cool man like i remember going
on tour and steve hansen was just like
son i just i just want you to not have
any expectation just come here enjoy
yourself
like just experience the environment and
literally that's what i did just
experienced that burn
was like a sponge
um enjoyed the aft after games enjoyed
the the fun and the beers of the lads
got to see how some of the boys you know
what they're really like
but honestly i sat in the room and i was
like oh like
i thought i thought the all black boys
like which they are i thought you know
was just like like you know yeah
seriously your hair down yeah serious
but um seeing that was pretty like
pretty eye-opening and yeah the whole
experience was cool bro no that's cool
one thing you spoke about before about
um when you first started you wouldn't
say a word you just sort of sat in the
back of the meetings and you wouldn't
really
contribute but mate one thing that i've
noticed which was awesome to watch
throughout your career was just the
growth of you
as a leader as a as a contributor and
now you your growth although it wasn't
it probably wasn't natural to be a
speaker look at you now you're
comfortable on podcast you host your own
podcast you've got you're doing all
these things now so what switched for
you to make that transition well
to be honest man like i still struggle
for now like like i mean with one-on-one
stuff yeah it's i find it easy small
groups easy but if i was to stand up
like i'm better this year in the last
couple years but
but i still kind of get like
i was scared like you know and um to
talk but
i think the massive [ __ ] i feel way more
comfortable is when i kept in the all
blacks and captain the canes like
i was not i was kind of like forced that
i had to because i was in this
leadership position
so i had to step up and i had to lead
and where once i did that
i was i just realized that oh it's not
that bad after all yeah you know but
still i still uh believe in
less talking and try and do the talking
through action and i feel like that's
the best way to try and earn respect
so yeah i think that was the massive
switches being put into that leadership
role and obviously when you're a leader
you have to step up and lead and
industry like talking and stuff so
um that was kind of the switch because i
was naturally like you say i'll just
chill don't say anything
and just go about my money but like i
think
at this part of my career i think it's
time to just step up and lead well i
think everyone still gets pretty nervous
when they have to speak in front of uh
groups and things like that but like you
say it is the more rich you do at
something yeah the more comfortable you
get it and
it's just putting yourself out there
initially i know
probably a little bit of fault of my own
but um back in the day keynes had a lot
of banter around guys who would stuff up
and things like that so probably never
helped encourage these guys to speak up
to be fair as well
you're you're always different though we
just knew we're just gonna have a laugh
and there was no like balance to it bro
sometimes
you're sitting on the cane's bus going
please
and talk to me a little bit more about
your cain's career you obviously
incredibly successful times at the cane
so i think you've won play of the year
pretty much every year you've played
championship 2016 you've touched on
2015 lost mate talk to me about your
hurricanes times man very like
love the club love the brothers and the
team um
create a lifelong friendships through
just playing with the canes man so
it's been pretty special um i guess
obviously to have bus there as well
that's even more special and then he
left and then come back and he's back in
the team so
yeah that's pretty unreal but yeah the
cain's journey has been awesome bro i
came into the team and probably around
similar time with you jabber and we're
quite lucky to have like i was lucky in
the lucy's to have like
jack lab fightfield
victor vito
kylie gibbons brad shields
like blade like both awesome guys
awesome rugby players
and was able to just learn off the ember
um and then they kind of left and then
that's where we kind of came through
but the journey's been awesome very i'm
still having cozy and
seeing the likes of like jordy starting
to step up and you know his team now to
to lead and all the young followers
coming through but it's um
it's pretty cool to see and um you know
having petty back
it's even better too so yeah yeah just
excited bro still get up still pinch
myself every time i put put the jersey
on and you've seen the squads the squads
have all been named are you happy with
what the hurricane's squad looks like
yeah 100 bro like
a mixture of
like older senior players
then you have like a little bit of
experienced players and then
we've got some mean as young talent
coming through that honestly there's
some freakish guys fast
strong it's pretty pretty
pretty nerve-wracking to see you but
keeps everyone on your toes but
that's why you signed for four years
you can't get rid of me now
who's really impressed yeah who do you
think's the next big gun oh boy from the
keynes like there's a few bro like just
from the top of my head like devon
flanders yeah um but he's he's he's a
beast uh braden from one two
um you know the likes of reuben love um
those those young brothers coming
through it's pretty awesome and yeah
those those three and billy billy prox
yeah yeah unsung hero bro
quiet dude but just like i said like
just goes about as a bucky yeah and you
know i love that bro yeah we're good
looking forward to the year from the
canes hopefully we can get another
championship sorted but one one thing
that happened in your career was uh when
you withdrew from the olympics one big
decision in your career talk to me about
that one and how hard that decision was
yeah
so it's um
like you know obviously i wanted to go
to olympics
had to play four tournaments and then i
played in that wellington sydney one
yeah so you know that was the goal bro
like you know had sunny rico aki the
mothers i was like okay we'll all go
um and it got to those two tournaments
bro and such was only putting me on for
like 30 seconds a minute each game yeah
but like
those four tournaments was meant for me
to get game time and and get to get the
flow going so i was like and wellington
getting like 30 seconds again
it's a cindy still coming off the bench
and i was like like
i love the i love the brothers
but like you know i came here to like
you know make a stamp and
but at the time that i came back to the
canes
after wellington sydney obviously i was
in 216 bro so our team was hussing
playing mean
um i happened to be playing pretty good
and then i just kind of asked my agent
like for i'd like to just play fifteens
and and stay
and then i made that decision bro
they were trying to get me to stay but i
didn't want to like
yeah come on for
a minute each game you know and and
obviously the canes was going well so i
decided to stick around and
lucky luckily i did bro because we won
the show that year
it was an awesome year bro so yeah
that's how
i came about my decision and why i kind
of chose to to stay with the 15s game
sure it's interesting so there's no
pressure from the new zealand rugby
union around all promises around the all
blacks that was just all
right that was just that's just all like
perception but like nah nah i heard
nothing i just wanted to stay with the
canes because we were playing men and i
was really enjoying my footy yeah but
like you say your decision did pay off
because then you would you did make the
all blacks and going into the
environment then what was it like yeah
but
it was pretty awesome bro i think it was
me alia dixon and liam squire coming in
as newbies so that was cool bro like i
did with the cage though just just a
sponge
quiet
just try to earn the respect of the
brothers just through what i do
um so yeah it was pretty cool man yeah i
i guess you've heard around the meetings
that we go into like you just you sit
there like shaking because you don't
know if he's going to ask you to speak
or
questions like that so
it's still is it still like that yeah a
little bit yeah yeah a little bit uh you
know through reviews and stuff you know
the boys getting asked questions and
stuff like that i think for me i've got
gotten better because i've been in the
team for a little bit now so yeah i'm
used to you know so but as a young fella
you're like
not looking at it these are nasty things
was that what was the hardest thing
about the transition to becoming an all
black from super rugby i think
the hardest thing back then if i if i'm
really honest bro was
um obviously at the canes it was more
free-flowing around the game structure
yeah like you know we were able to just
jab you know like give the ball
one-on-ones where the abs
like as a lucy it was just like at that
time
it was around just cleaning rocks yeah
and that stuff and
don't get me wrong i love cleaning ruxin
as part of my job but i wasn't able to
do
the stuff that i was good at so that was
the hardest transition and
and trying to like
change my game to fit a certain mould
yeah so i think looking back like that
was probably the hardest kind of thing
for me and the transition around that is
that just because it was so structured
the game plan that you were trying to
play yeah well like you look at the
all blacks always
the seven jersey was pretty much based
around like the goat rich
richie and
you know and then you have someone like
me who's trying to do skunky long balls
or step step quack
um you know so
um looking back bro like actually doing
that stuff really helped my game because
i was able to like get really good at
the the basic stuff
you know that like that the little stuff
that that matters um but yeah it was
hard at first to
kind of get used to that so now the role
is
suited around your style of play
oh
probably not it's it's way more the
stretch is way more
um
still the same actually
it's all the same i don't know
i don't even know what i'm saying but
like it feels like there's a bit more
kind of freedom to express yourself or
further game plan if that makes sense
yeah nice and talk to me about the rugby
world cup a huge moment going to the
rugby world cup obviously a dream of
yours to represent all blacks at a rugby
world cup how was that experience well
it was pretty um like you know there's a
lot of hype around that talk around it
but when you actually earn it bro like
it kind of just feels like like another
kind of game like you come to mind it's
like you don't try and build that hype
in your head
but the experience braille being in
japan you couldn't even walk out the
door of the hotel because it was just
packed yeah like just the whole way the
whole atmosphere was unreal bro
um especially in japan
they loved their 40 like true fans over
there but yeah in terms of the the games
it was just like the mindset was like
it's another game week by week and that
was it and once we reached like the
quarters and you know it was just each
game's a final and obviously was pretty
[ __ ] that we lost the semis yeah to
england
but
luckily enough we we get to go again at
23 and hopefully you know we make the
squad
and then try and rectify it again bro
100 and one thing that happened was you
ripped the the goggles first first time
where yeah was one of the one of the
coolest things that i've seen on the
rugby field for a while i remember
watching that game we i was at the
stadium when you wore them and i just
remember seeing guys like pull on them
and like slap it across the back of your
head and i was like that doesn't look
good
oh
it was the worst place to try them out
because of the humidity in japan
like it was crazy and then i wore them
in the game
yeah because like i was like doubting it
oh [ __ ] what are people going to think
and
but like the boys are now it's good
but as soon as bro i was like over like
just bridging over a rock
in the book
grabbed it right just like pulled it and
i looked up and
he was just like smiling at me like just
read off in like i was like fire these
guys are messing with my head so that's
how i took it off
and just threw it
oh it's so funny
okay
so then they're not going to make a
comeback uh if they find a way where it
can stay on your head and it's like
comfortable
and and the contact area but i'll wear
them like yeah to protect my eye but at
the moment like what's just the strap
it's just real easy to like
just move around
like you're playing in your your faces
like
like scrunched up
oh so good did you think about trialling
them before the world cup was there ever
a thought or did you think it was going
to be all good to just square at the
world cup well i didn't know about the
goggles until like the pool games in the
world cup yeah because i was i was just
like
i knew i had problems with my left eye
yeah and it wasn't so real
i was like doing this to my eyes
and i realized that this was real blind
like i can't see but if you go all blue
when i see you
then i just happen to open my mouth to
doc
and then doc was like we're not all
serious and was like
did all this research and i was like
mate you need to wear these goggles
because pretty much like my left eye it
can't get any better
um so if i get a knock to the side
i could potentially be blind that's
right so that was what he was saying
he's like well you got to protect the
pretend i was like mate i've been
playing like this all good
he's like now you got to wear it got to
wear it try it and he spoke to steve and
steve was like suddenly you know you got
to wear this
it's a great example for young players
and a lot of the people you inspire so
as soon as he said that i was like okay
for the people
um yeah so
tried them and didn't work out as well
as i would like but if there were better
ones definitely bro definitely try it
did your left eye get damaged from a
incident in rugby it's from rubbing too
much so my cornea it's like scratched so
like you think of a wood screen and
there's like a crack
crack in the middle of it yeah that's
pretty much what it is so
it's from like it's like you know how
you get hay fever yeah you probably
heard me in meetings like snapping my
nose and stuff and that's from rubbing
my eyes
true and i just scratched it yeah too
strong
[Laughter]
there is cons to being super strong
but
off off the rugby field obviously
there was a time where you did decide
that it was time to sort of did you
consciously decide that it was time to
grow your brand when you started to
bring out the podcast and the
the clothing brand what
how did that sort of come about yeah
it's real weird but like i remember
starting sevens and instagram just came
out yeah and it was like you know i was
like oh yeah i'll just contract post the
photo
and organically throughout my career bro
as instagram got bigger
my career just kind of went from sevens
lions canes so it just kind of just
slowly i just slowly built
like organically without even knowing
that brand and i kind of the podcast
wasn't around like building my brand was
more around probably the same as you
jabber around like just
having a space where athletes can come
and
actually be themselves and talk around
stories
to fans instead of going to media that
kind of write and twist the words a
little bit yeah
um but like starting the podcast just in
turn happened to build the brand without
even knowing
um the clothing side of things bro it
was more
like oh i like was watching kanye west
that was easy brand
and was like oh that's pretty cool
i might start my own brand and i thought
i was pretty gangster you know when i
was 18 so
i started that more so because i just
wanted to own my own kind of thing yeah
i didn't know it was like a business at
the time yeah i just wanted to like
be in control of something
and then without even knowing that kind
of just grew
as i grew
throughout my career and as a man and
just learning about business so
like it wasn't necessary the reason
wasn't necessary to start to build the
personal brand it was just like to do it
because out of my interest then
the result of that was just around like
my brand just organically kind of grew
if that made sense yeah yeah that's cool
so how does your clothing brand work now
when you're on tour and stuff who who
runs the shippers at all your wife yeah
yes so i do all the creative stuff like
the designing
um
i try draw it and then put it into
digital form
um
and then get it all sent over
and then starts all the logistical side
like so the emails the making sure
all the little niggly stuff there
sometimes i still really like to do yeah
um emails she does that and i do the
creative side she does the cons and all
that
and while i'm on tour bro it's easy for
me just to
at nighttime just sit there and just
like write ideas draw ideas
yes so that's pretty much how it works
very nice and simple
still kind of still trying to learn how
to grow and scale it
but
you know all a good time what's been the
hardest thing about running your own
business
um
i reckon for me right now though is
learning how to like scale it like
we're in a position where our stuff goes
pretty quick which is cool but then it's
like what's next how can we
scale it bigger so it grows and the
brand grows um
that's probably that the hardest thing
at the moment is like we're just making
stuff like deciding on we'll do this
hoodie or like five hoodies and this but
financially is it the right thing in
terms of you know investing it stuff
like that bro
so just
challenging to still understand that i
think over the summer we'll have time to
kind of talk to the right people and and
hopefully learn and grow is it just you
and your wife working for you now we
have uh joseph who's one of the also
that run uncommon
we stole all our stuff there and then he
kind of
does all like the middle stuff that we
miss
so he's crucial to us too bro and he
helps also
um helps me kind of
do the designs as well
right that's exciting looking forward to
seeing it scale and grow to yeah empire
it's going to be
oh yeah
hopefully
hopefully all good if it doesn't
another thing you've been big on
throughout your rugby career is you've
been a big advocate for mental health
you've always been open to sharing your
stories um
giving other people a platform to share
theirs what's been the biggest learnings
throughout your rugby career around
mental health any any sort of advice
um
i don't know if it's advice but like
what kind of works for me is
i like to just do stuff that makes me
happy yeah in terms of
finding what that is is just trying
friends different things that you're
interested in and
if you get that feeling of like man this
is awesome and then do more of it and do
less of the things that upset you or
or put you in a [ __ ] mood
so that's like one of the things that i
do so one thing i love to do bro is
coffee connects like going to cafes and
one of these
texting the lads to go for coffee
that's pretty cool able to just sit
there talk
not nothing about rugby but yeah i think
a big thing for me bro is um
at this stage is like
getting myself right and making sure my
family's happy and everything's all good
because if that's like when that's
sorted but i'm able to do all this other
stuff yeah and in a good manner yeah
that's so true and how is the family how
how are you beautiful kids now
yeah they're good but like
my son's turned one in october just
started walking like last week yeah so
you know i watched that over over face
time like my daughter's she's growing
older her birthday's in december
um but yeah the kids are getting older
bro and yeah so i'm seeing them tomorrow
so i'm holding up where i'm holding it
they're gonna be stoked
and what are your plans going forward
you obviously signed with new zealand
rugby union for four years plans on and
off the field what have you got um
man i like obviously is to keep for over
the summer but obviously the ultimate
goal was to be available and play for
the canes win a championship with them
with the brothers
and then obviously make the all blacks
and just have a powerful year in a
positive way bro
that's kind of my goal and then
off field brothers just to keep working
at making sure my family's all good and
i'm all good and then
i just keep doing what i'm doing and
hopefully create a gateway for players
and and people just to
to navigate and
um yeah there's a lot of things that i
want to do though sometimes it's a
bloody
it's a bad thing because there's too
much stuff on my table but um
yeah still learning bro you are such a
lad at just hearing those goals oh it
gets me
excited anyway mate we've gone to our
instagram for some question as always
well the man himself when he comes on
brings in plenty of questions we've got
heaps
uh first question
are you sure
i do say that to everyone but no you
all black legend you have actually got
heaps
i've just chosen maybe i've chosen about
10. will the pirates ever win the mini
team tournament
this is their year
[Laughter]
chrono sent that one and he's obviously
sick of seeing the pirates struggle and
the mini team comp at the canes chrono
wrecks the many team challenges there
here exit too many quizzes for the
pirates he reckons
okay what leaders have been an
inspiration to your leadership style
um
i'd say cozy
he's a man with a few words yeah uh and
just goes hard and leads by action and
another one is uh
paddy toops yeah
yeah like i love the way he's it's again
just quiet but goes about his work and
the probably biggest one was karen reed
just around how he operated under
pressure and how he delivered messages
um that was pretty cool all right nice
three good options there
okay any tips for crypto
all right
to be honest bro i've just started
investing like two three weeks ago oh
true yeah um
yeah
uh but
yeah funny man like tj was telling us to
do it 15 weeks ago but like you know
that kind of feeling of that no
then obviously yeah uh i didn't probably
have any advice man um i just kind of
invested in bitcoin and ethereum at the
moment yeah and just kind of been
um putting in
like a
small amount that i'm comfortable with
once a week yeah just kind of like let's
see where it goes
nice
yeah no not an expert i think the best
person to ask would be tj he's he's a
guru at this at the moment he loves it
uh he was right over in japan yeah
that's right okay next one if you could
choose one player to come across to the
canes who would it be
uh
from a super team
anywhere
anywhere
but i would go
just just because i just seen his
highlights and he looks like a beast
joshua oh
[Laughter]
he's not very tall i just built
absolutely yeah
i've never seen him before i've never
seen him before though but um obviously
bus played off from him
when i hear boss saying
he's the real bus
he's a real buster must mean something
yeah
okay next one who would be the last man
standing in a mma battle in the all
blacks
he'll be one of the front rollers
i'll take it um
i'd uh
shucks
sure i don't know surely
yeah
you have a mean choker
i remember those wrestling sessions in
pre-season you were you were good
no way i'm just a box sucker
now
mma
on two
yeah probably nipple oh yeah
just so strong
yeah aki because he's tall and yeah got
the long reach
yeah
nice okay next one how many people have
fallen for the dummy uh every single one
of them
i can't cut
[Laughter]
what's the story behind the dummy
oh my i've i've been doing that since i
was at first 15 yeah at school and it's
funny because salisi
he always gives me [ __ ] about it because
obviously he used to watch me at school
and he's like yeah
he's he's seen it
but yeah people don't understand like
the reasoning why i do it but um
yeah i reckon people fall for it people
fall for it when when you say the
reasoning for you do it what is that
yeah so like even though i dummy and
people don't do that one thing but yeah
huge gap
for me it's like when i dummy
it creates that like split second pause
even if they don't go that christians go
bang
and that's all i that's all i need for
them to go back and you're not able to
try and
go and attack a weak shoulder there we
go that'll
clarify it for the
listeners eh everyone i just dropped
someone to go chasing it with me isaac
now i'm gonna do it someone's just gonna
go faster
okay next question how loose was it
partying with the panthers after the
premiership yeah um
but they had been on like that was like
their fourth day celebrating so they're
quite like mellow just chilling out but
yeah the lads our leds were like excited
they went hard me and tj when drinking
wood we drove the bed oh yeah because
they're about an hour away from half an
hour away from us so cow let's we're
like pumping going hard because we had
the week off yeah but the pampers boys
were quite just like
you know when you're on the fourth day
on the person
yeah
yeah
so they were pretty they went too bad
actually yeah and did you manage to have
a conversation with them did you manage
to get to meet many of those guys yeah
heaves bro it was crazy bro like and
how um an awe they were of the all
blacks and you know a lot of this stuff
they based on the after all blacks and
sure like pretty much saying the same
like we like admire you guys or what you
guys are doing and
then like you know when they celebrate
their try scoring and you know like
authentic so
that was pretty cool bro
like again just like normal dudes
just like us yeah that just happened to
be gangster on the field yeah yeah
it's crazy you obviously shut the gate
on playing you know around yeah it was
it was something that you were looking
at for a while there how do you feel
about that situation yeah bro like
obviously like in 219 like post 219 i
kind of came across my mind to give it a
crack
just something different um and freshen
up but then i got injured and real cut
and it took me out for the season so
that was kind of
scratched um and then my mind just
shifted to just
playing footy and playing rugby but i
always had wanted to and like kind of
that reason was to kind of represent the
torso more because obviously the
eligibility rules are different in
league
so that was kind of the whole reasoning
and also
just trying league and giving it a crack
that goes on to the next question a
little bit is thoughts on jules playing
for samoa so i'm guessing you've shut
the gate on
playing for samoa now too with this
four-year deal pretty much
um but jules has still got the option to
give it a go yeah um i haven't really
spoken to him about it but he would
probably say the same thing like if he
um if he was good enough and he was
playing good footy to represent the blue
jersey then that'd be an option but yeah
i'm not too sure what what the bro wants
to do it makes sense to to to go and try
and play
uh but i'm not too sure in regards to
myself bro i'm starting till 25 you
never know
i guess if the stand down of three years
changes to less yeah
potentially potentially but um yeah
stick around in new zealand for a bit
but you've met sort of mentioned moana
pacifica at the start is that something
that really interests you to make that
switch to that side yeah or like that's
why i had that clause in my super rugby
contract which just keep my options open
not saying i'll go um you know i love
the canes but i was just to keep my
options open and if
if it was the right time then
potentially would
and just go you know and
and play my part and and if i was good
enough but um yeah it's more to
it's it's an option it's an option yeah
if you were good enough of course yeah
yeah of course you're good enough
you never know you never know what
happens in a year or two
yeah
okay last question
arti savia's best advice
best advice holy [ __ ]
this will be good mate you're an
inspiring man i'm gonna say it but i i
kind of got it from one of the brothers
um
they kind of told it to me and it kind
of like inspired me i was
be unapologetically you
um yeah if people don't like it then
they don't like it and if they bible
fear they vibe with you but um rico rico
said that to me
and i like really i really really like
yeah i like that so
that's my advice you live by that too
yeah
yeah just just just trying to be amiibo
yeah
that would look cool on one of your
t-shirts too actually i like that one
yeah i've just gotta uh run it past rex
and how much percentage he wants from it
from the sales
but he's too busy invested in that dodgy
dvd still that we pranked them off
yeah
oh my absolute pleasure having you on
the podcast stoked to be able to get you
on and go through your journey mate
you're an absolute legend someone i love
playing with um someone who's inspired
me so much throughout my footy career
and post-footy career as well so mates
awesome to have you on and you're still
right at the top of your game with a
huge future ahead so mate really
appreciate you coming on the podcast and
giving up your time thanks deb i
appreciate you my brother proud of you
man inspiring all of us too
you're a legion
[Music]
what
[Music]